Alright, so this part is very short, but it's really, really important that you do it.
The reason why is because you want to make sure that you are protected legally in the
future for your website.
And so we go to the very bottom, right here, where it says Side Power by Nick Wood, you're
going to click in this section that Weebly automatically creates for you.
So this is not a section that we made previously in our framing asset video.
This is something that is automatically created for you.
So once you have created this, this is where we're going to add the terms of service for
your website, the privacy policy, and this is where you're going to add the fact that
you're affiliated to your client and you can also add, and it would suggest you're doing
so to avoid any trouble, you're going to add the contractor license of your client
right here at the bottom.
So let's get it started.
You're going to drag the text right here, okay?
You're going to add another text right here.
Alright, and we like to use this free tool called Terms Feed that generates privacy policies
for you.
It's very simple.
So I already have this pulled up, you're going to search for app.termsfeed.com and it's going
to take you right here and we are going to generate the terms and conditions first.
So click on here, click on start, select website, okay, the URL is whatever we bought earlier
from GoDaddy.
So make sure you copy and paste that in here.
The name of the website is in my case, Queen Creek Concrete, payment individual, oops,
individual, okay, enter, make sure the correct country is selected, select your state, no,
no, okay, this is going to be by visiting a page on our website, which again, put the
domain in here and the phone number is whatever you purchased on CallRail.
Let's see, hopefully I don't have to pull that back up for you.
Okay, your tracking number, so copy and paste it, next step, email address, so wherever
you want this privacy policy to be sent to, okay, generate and boom.
So you're going to copy this, now open a new tab, paste that in there, click search
and it's right here.
So copy this link again and you're going to, right at the bottom, you're going to type
terms and conditions, select all of it, insert a link, a website URL, you're going to paste
that same link, click out of it, reselect, let's bold it, underline it and let's make
it a color so people know that they can click on it, can make it red, perfect.
And now we are going to, let's align this, okay, actually delete the spacer right here
and again, make sure you add there, you're an affiliated company with your client and
put the license and contractor, okay, we're going to name this privacy policy, okay, back
to terms feed, so we can close this out, click on the logo, it should take you back to the
homepage, okay, perfect, privacy policy start, website, same thing, phone number, I would
just keep every tab open with everything that you need because these keep reoccurring and
you always need them so I would just leave it like it is, same as earlier, individual
United States, make sure you're putting every information correctly, email first number,
first name and phone number, visiting, same, oops, that's fine, put that phone number,
next step, no, we just want the basic one and generate, oops, boom, copy this, same
thing as we did earlier, I do this just to double check it looks correctly, you copy,
go back to Weebly, select everything, link it to a website URL, click out of it, now
we're going to make this bold, okay, now we're going to test it really quick, so click on
publish and that little footer is nice because it should copy automatically on every other
service page, so let's just pick a random one, it should be at the very bottom, perfect,
so we're just going to test it, click on both of them and make sure it takes you here and
you're done, that's all you need to do for that.